BY NOW YOU HAVE PROBABLY
HEARD ABOUT YESTERDAY'S BIG
NEWS OUT OF CINCINNATI.
>> THIS WHITE POLICE OFFICER
HAS NOW BEEN INDICTED FOR
THE MURDER OF AN UNARMED
BLACK MAN.
RAY TENSING, THE NOW FIRED
UNIVERSITY OF CINCINNATI
POLICE OFFICER HAS BEEN
INDICTED BY AN OHIO GRAND
JURY ON MURDER CHARGES.
>> Larry: HOLD ON ONE
SECOND.
CAN YOU SHOW ME THE WAY CNN
INTRODUCED US TO THAT MURDER
VICTIM.
IS THAT HIS MUG SHOT?
THIS GUY WAS JUST KILLED BY
THE OTHER GUY AND YOU PUT
THEIR TWO MUG SHOTS TOGETHER
LIKE THEY'RE A BANK ROBBING
TEAM?
I MEAN, I GET T HE MAY HAVE
HAD A RECORD BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT VICTIM MEANS, RIGHT,
CNN?
WELL, LOOK, THEY
SUBSEQUENTLY HLOWED OTHER
PICTURES OF THE GUY.
BUT I TELL YOU WHAT, LET ME
ASK YOU A FAVOR, IF I
EVER GET SHOT BY THE COPS,
CNN, PLEASE USE A PICTURE OF
ME WITH MY KIDS.
I DON'T WANT TO BE
REMEMBERED BY THE ONE TIME I
WENT ON THAT COOKING METH
BENDER WITH NICK NOLTE.
THAT WOULD BE HORRIBLE.
IT WOULD BE HORRIBLE.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
I DID THAT ONE TIME!
NOW GUYS, I KNOW WE'VE
REPORTED ON THESE TYPES OF
STORIES A LOT.
AND IF IT FEELS LIKE THE
NIGHTLY SHOW IS GETTING A
LITTLE REPETITIVE.
I AGREE.
AT THIS POINT MY WRITING
STAFF JUST HAS TO FILL IN
THE NAMES.
THEY BARELY EVEN SHOW UP TO
WORK ANY MORE.
AND I WILL BE HONEST WITH
YOU, I DON'T WANT TO KEEP
TALKING ABOUT THESE
INCIDENTS AM BUT THEY KEEP
HAPPENING.
I MEAN IF I HAD MY WAY, THIS
SHOW WOULD JUST BE LARRY
WILMORE TALKS ABOUT HIS
FAVORITE BATTLESTAR
GALACTICA EPISODES FOR A
HALF HOUR EVERY NIGHT.
THAT'S IT.
SO WHAT HAPPENED.
HOW DID THIS ESCALATE TO THE
POINT WHERE A MAN IS DEAD?
CNN, I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU
ANOTHER CHANCE HERE, SHED
SOME LIGHT ON THIS FOR US.
>> AN OFFICER CAN ORDER
SOMEONE OUT OF A CAR FOR
JUST A VALID TRAFFIC STOP.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT RIGHT UP
UNTIL THAT EXIT ORDER, HE'S
PROBABLY ACTING
CONSTITUTIONALLY.
AND THEN OF COURSE, HE PULLS
HIS GUN AND HE SHOOTS HIM.
>> Larry: OH, RIGHT, THAT
LITTLE  DETAIL.
IT TAKES A KEEN JUDICIAL
EYE TO SEE IT BUT YEAH,
WE'RE LIKE 95% SURE THE PART
WHERE IT ALL GOES WRONG IS
THE SHOOTING IN THE FACE.
SO IT IS ALL GOING ACCORDING
TO A FAMILIAR SCRIPT SO FAR.
BUT THERE IS SOMETHING
DIFFERENT ABOUT THIS STORY.
HERE IS HAMILTON COUNTY
PROSECUTOR JOE DETERS
YESTERDAY.
>> IT'S JUST SENSELESS.
THIS IS THE MOST ASSININE
ACT I'VE EVER SEEN A POLICE
OFFICER MAKE.
THIS IS WITHOUT QUESTION A
MURDER.
I'M TREATING HIM LIKE A
MURDERER.
>> Larry: WHOOO!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> YES!
OH MY GOD LAM!
THE COP WHO MURDERED THE GUY
IS ACTUALLY GETTING TREATED
LIKE A MURDERER?
[BLEEP] MAN!
THERE'S A  STRANGE PATTERN, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
IT IS LIKE THE COPS ARE
ENGAGED IN SOME DARK GAME OF
TRIVIAL PURSUIT WITH BLACK
PEOPLE OR SOMETHING.
I MEAN SANDRA BLAND PULLED
OVER FOR NOT USING A BLINKER
ENDS UP DEAD. ERIC GARNER SOLD
LOOSE
CIGARETTES ENDS UP DEAD, WALTER
SCOTT
BROKEN TAILLIGHT DEAD,
MICHAEL BROWN, J WALKING,
DEAD.
AND WHAT REALLY TAKES IT TO
THE NEXT LEVEL N THIS
CINCINNATI CASE IS WHEN YOU
START TO LOOK AT HOW THIS
COULD HAVE PLAYED OUT.
>> AND ONE OF THE MOST
CONCERNING THINGS IS THIS
POLICE INCIDENT REPORT FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF CINCINNATI
TAKEN SHORTLY AFTER THIS ALL
HAPPENED.
AND IT SAYS THAT THE OFFICER
TENSING SAYS THAT HE WAS
BEING DRAGGED BY THE CAR AS
THE DRIVER WAS TAKING OFF.
AND THAT HE WAS ALMOST
KILLED AND RUN OVER BY THE
DRIVER OF THE HONDA.
>> Larry: WELL, THAT SOUNDS
TERRIBLE, OF COURSE, THAT'S
JUST WHAT HE SAID.
HOLD ON.
IS ANYONE ELSE CORROBORAT
ING THIS.
>> TWO OFFICERS
THAT ARRIVED AT THE SCENE
SEEM TO CORROBORATE THAT IN
THEIR
STATEMENTS.
>> OKAY.
HOLD ON, HOLD ON.
THIS IS PRETTY WELL
CORROBORATED, YOU GUYS.
IS THERE ANYTHING OUT THERE
THAT CAN UNCORROBORATE ALL
THIS CORROBORATION.
>> THE FACT IS, PROSECUTING
ATTORNEY SAYS THERE IS
NOTHING IN THAT VIDEO
THAT SHOWS THAT AT ALL.
>> Larry: OH, THERE'S A
VIDEO.
WELL, LET'S JUST SEE WHAT
THIS VIDEO HAS TO SAY.
I MEAN NOT LIKE ALL VIDEOS
ARE INNOCENT, RIGHT?
YOU KNOW VIDEO DID KILL THE
RADIO STAR, YOU KNOW THAT.
>> SEVERAL MORE TIMES
TENSING ASKED DUBOSE FOR HIS
LICENCE AND THEN SOMETHING
HAPPENED.
>> OKAY.
>> I HAVE TO FIGURE OUT IF
YOU HAVE A LICENCE.
GO AHEAD AND TAKE YOUR SEAT
BELT OFF.
>> GO AHEAD AND TAKE YOUR
SEAT BELT OFF.
>> STOP, STOP.
>> LESS THAN TWO MINUTES
AFTER TENSING APPROACHED,
TENSING FIRES A SINGLE SHOT
HITTING DUBOSE IN THE HEAD,
KILLING DUBOSE AS THE CAR
STARTS TO MOVE.
TENSING CHASES AFTER THE CAR,
AND ANOTHER OFFICER ARRIVES.
>> Larry: OKAY SO, BASICALLY
MOTHER [BLEEP] YOU JUST
LIED.
OKAY.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
(APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
IT'S REALLY THAT SIMPLE.
AND THEN YOUR BUDDIES
COVERED UP YOUR LIE.
THIS IS WHAT IS SO [BLEEP]
INFURIATEING TO ME.
AND THIS ISN'T THE FIRST
TIME A BLACK MAN HAS DIED AT
THE HANDS OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CINCINNATI POLICE
DEPARTMENT IT IS JUST THE
FIRST TIME IT WAS CAUGHT ON
BODY CAM.
AND I KNOW THERE WAS A
DEBATE ABOUT BODY CAMERA,
BUT I'M PRO GOPRO, ALL RIGHT?
RIGHT?
IF THIS HADN'T BEEN CAPTURED
ON CAMERA, SAMUEL DUBOSE
WOULD STILL BE DEAD, RAY
TENSING WOULD STILL BE ON
THE STREET AND THIS EPISODE
OF THE NIGHTLY SHOW WOULD
ALL BE ABOUT BSG WHERE BLOOMER
SHOOTS ADAMA AND YOU WOULD BE
LIKE NO, MAN WHO IS GOING TO
COMMAND THE FLEET NOW.
CASE CLOSED, BAD GUY IS BEHIND
BARS.
COUNTY PROSECUTOR JOE
DETERS PUT IT BEST.
>> PURPOSEFUL KILLING OF
ANOTHER, THAT IS WHAT MAKES
IT MURDER.
HE PURPOSEFULLY KILLED HIM.
>> Larry: WOW.
THAT IS VERY STRONG LANGUAGE.
AND YOU KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE
IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY WERE
SURPRISED WITH HOW
FORTHRIGHT THIS PROSECUTOR
WAS.
THEY ARE NOT USED TO HEARING
OFFICIALS TALK LIKE THAT.
ACTUALLY, THEY'RE NOT USING
TO HEARING THIS OFFICIAL
TALK LIKE THAT.
BECAUSE JUST RECENTLY HE
SOUNDED LIKE THIS.
>> HERE'S HOW PROSECUTOR
DETERS DESCRIBED A GROUP OF
AFRICAN-AMERICANS WHO
ALLEGEDLY BEAT UP A WHITE
MAN, QUOTE, THEY WILL HURT
YOU.
THEY WILL HURT YOUR GRANDMA.
THE ROOT CAUSE OF THIS IS
THERE IS NO DISCIPLINE IN
THE HOME.
THEY DON'T GO TO SCHOOL, YOU
KNOW, THEY LIVE OFF THE
GOVERNMENT.
NO PERSONAL ACCOUNTABILITY.
THEY JUST BEAT PEOPLE UP AND
FOR NO REASON.
>> Larry: NOW HE SAID THIS
LAST MONTH, NOT YEARS AGO
WHEN RACISM WAS COOL.
NOW LOOK, WHEN THIS IS HOW
YOU TALK ABOUT AN ENTIRE
COMMUNITY THAT YOU ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE WORKING WITH,
WHEN YOU PAINT THEM AS "THEY"
AND YOU TALK ABOUT THEM LIKE
THEY ARE LESS THAN HUMAN, IS
IT ANY WONDER THAT IT HAS
LEAD TO INCIDENTS LIKE THIS
IN THAT VERY COMMUNITY.
I MEAN SERIOUSLY, DID WE
LEARN NOTHING FROM BATTLE
STAR GALACTICA?